Ali is with us in Denver hey Ali welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank you
nervous no trouble what's up
I am 49 year old 8 ha ha I have three
kids at home my husband passed away
about a year and a half ago oh my
goodness what happened she has heart
stopped in his sleep okay yeah my dad
just of 12 and when he graduates I would
like I see myself leaving the area
moving to a different area but meanwhile
I'm having a hard time staying in this
home with the memories and all and I'd
like to move us to a different house for
the next five years
mm-hmm that I'm just wondering if that's
the financially responsible thing to do
what is your home worth about five
hundred okay and how are you your
stay-at-home mom so that must mean there
was a large life-insurance policy or
what
yes very large I have no debt no
mortgage I have cars there paid off I
have about nine hundred thousand in
investments and about fifty thousand in
the bank you know that is that is so
wonderful I'm so glad to hear that part
of the story the other poem appear the
most in this in my situation well
actually you know it I appreciate your
statement you're blessed is what you are
I don't think luck anything to do with
it you guys were very intentional and
obviously he did a great job of making
sure his family was taken care of that's
right yeah I don't have to work when we
get survivor benefits from Social
Security so I just use that I remember
to keep us going
sure okay don't touch any of the other
money okay so if you sold the home it
would bring $500,000 cash in your hand
right right can you buy another home
that is what you're thinking about for
five hundred thousand yes if the lateral
move okay I know there's expenses
involved no you lose a little bit here
or there but you might move up or down
or you might lose a little tiny bit of
your investments to make up the
difference or something so
you know if you come out of pocket 50
grand or something and make this move
you're still gonna get the money back
because Denver's a wonderful real estate
market as you know and you're gonna yeah
it's gonna go you know five years from
now when you get ready to resell it
you're gonna make money on it agreed I
believe yeah hopefully yeah I think you
well I really do I mean Denver's done
very very well unless the market just
economics just crash or something but I
mean it would be very unusual I
personally would be very comfortable
investing if I were you in a different
home about the same price range and as
you said to kind of put some of those
the unpleasant memories behind you and
be in a different situation because it's
it's gotta be weird to walk in there
every day right it's you can't look
anywhere without yeah feeling there and
it's really really hard to live that way
sure sure
well it's extending the grief it's
making the grief worse is what amounts
to is what you're saying for you and
probably the kids as well so yeah I'm
moving I'm with you let's put it up for
sale move okay so you don't think it'll
affect our overall picture and we look
okay financially their overall picture
is very strong I'm very proud of what he
did and not what you guys did to prepare
for this unusual unusually early passing
and so forth yeah I definitely
definitely would make the move how long
did you say he passed he was 48 yeah
okay all right yeah yeah I the reason I
ask is I try not to make major decisions
in the early days after someone passes
because that's when we're the most torn
up you know what I'm saying yeah like
you can you it's still hard to breathe
but you can breathe better than you
could a year and a half ago yeah and so
that that way I know your heads pretty
clear on this decision but yeah I'm
doing it if I'm you I'm with you get in
touch with one of our endorsed local
providers at Dave Ramsey comm click them
for real estate they'll list it and get
the most they can possibly get out of it
for you tell them your whole story and
they'll help you find something and you
make this move very very easy with a
good professional in your corner and I
just check LP at Dave Ramsey comm for
real estate and they'll help you walk
right through it
I'm so sorry you guys are facing this
but I also want to tip my hat to him and
to you for the great job that you all
did in preparing in that he had you know
the right amount of life insurance to
where this family is taking care of this
story changes completely people if he
had no life insurance it would be a real
mess I mean it's hard the way it is it's
very hard the way it is but Wow
there'd be a real mess